saw Inception
or at least I dreamed I did
twice right we should drop them no he's
not right we're not where would we even
drop it Phyllis I am planning a bomb
scare that should really get the blood
pumping that's not gonna happen
um
well yeah I mean what is what no you
can't party um
whoa awesome let's put a smile on that
face
damn it Creed I've been up since four
wanna see a magic trick I'm gonna make a
pencil visible
disappear
hey
Michael and I have a very special
connection he's like Batman unlike Robin
he's like the Lone Ranger and I'm like
Tonto and it's not like there was the
Lone Ranger and Tonto and bonto
hey children
I'm Michael Scott and I am in charge of
this place
uh how do I make you understand I am
like Superman and the people who work
here are like citizens of Gotham City
that's Batman okay I'm Aquaman where
does he live guys the ocean
I work with a bunch of nerds
seemed kind of random to me but he was
pretty clear on who he thought truly
deserved this boondoggle of a Lifetime
well he nailed it because I do deserve a
vacation
sometimes Batman's gotta take off his
cape
can you confirm that the straps are
tight
yes
but this and now the chains
a lot of people think that magic Camp is
just for kids and that's why so many
other people in my class were kids
self-fulfilling prophecy it's um
really for anybody with a dream and a
belief in Magic and a little extra time
after school
magic magic magic
and now
Michael the magic will attempt to escape
from extreme bondage
can he do it I don't see how he can I
know how
dislocate his shoulder and slip his arm
out
no everyone now count down with me three
sorry quick thing so is it true that if
you can't get out you don't want anyone
to help you I will get out oh yes I will
so we shouldn't help you no matter how
much you might beg and please no all
right just this is getting hot so let's
just do this okay ready three
two one go
[Applause]
is everything okay Michael
yes
I cannot tell you how I plan to escape
other than by using magic that is the
Magician's Code
separately on an unrelated note if you
happen to find a small
brass key
this is from Hooters yeah it's a
business lunch did Toby approve this no
he did not I don't need his permission
you just got your corporate credit card
back you really want me to take it away
again it's ridiculous they took my card
away because I spent 80 bucks at a magic
shop what they don't understand is that
I bought the stuff to impress potential
clients so business related right I put
a cigarette through a freaking quarter I
guess I forgot well I guess I forgot to
give you a donut
if I had to I could clean out my desk in
five seconds and nobody would ever know
I had ever been here
and I'd forget to
first up the lost and found has gone
missing it itself is lost so please try
not to lose anything until we find it oh
okay you know what you clearly don't
care so why don't you just leave I would
like to stay this pertains to me why
don't you go outside and take a shot of
insulin and have a nap okay why do you
always assume I have diabetes I don't
know your frame your build why don't you
have a glass of apple juice and tell me
you're not a diabetic I am Michael Scott
I am the captain of this party I'm
Captain Jack I'm captain of the ship ah
I'm also captain of anyone who sets foot
on the ship hi looking forward
okay in an office when you are ranking
people manager is higher than captain
on a boat who knows it's nebulos
War goes on forever and Ryan gets
drafted wait sorry I said that I didn't
just part of meant it
besides he'd end up being a hero anyway
I come from a long line of Fighters my
maternal grandfather was the toughest
guy I ever knew World War II veteran
killed 20 men then spent the rest of the
war in an Allied prison camp
my father
battled blood pressure and obesity all
his life
different kind of fight you know
sometimes
to get perspective
I like to think about a space man on a
star incredibly far away
and our problems don't matter to him
because we're just a distant point of
light
but he feels sorry for me
because he has an incredibly powerful
microscope and he can see my face
I'm okay
no I'm not
stop it stop what you're talking about
me in Morse code
you know what jokes on you because I
know Morse code
that's what we're doing
and our very limited free time and with
our very limited budget we went and got
a nanny and then we went out and took a
class on a very outmoded and very
unnecessary form of communication just
so we could talk about you in front of
you
yep that's exactly what we did
it all started when Dwight was tapping
his foot against the leg of his desk
when I asked him to stop he said I will
when you lose the baby weight
very well I must have imagined it I
apologize
detonator
where
Michael
Jim are you clicking a detonator
it's a pin Michael come on get back to
work Dwight please
fine
hey Tap Away